ratio of the number of chocolates gaurav
received to the number of chocolates
chair received is two is to three
and that can also be written as two by
three
we have seen that two by 3 can be
written in different ways
we can multiply the numerator as well as
the denominator by 2 and get 4 by 6
or we can also multiply the numerator
and the denominator by 3 to get 6 by
nine
all these three ratios have the same
value
if we multiply the numerator and the
denominator by the same value the ratio
remains unchanged
even if we divide the numerator and the
denominator by the same value the ratio
remains unchanged
let's consider the ratio twelve by
eighteen
we can divide the numerator as well as
the denominator by six
the numerator will be twelve by six
and the denominator will be eighteen by
six
twelve by six is two
and eighteen by six is three
twelve by eighteen and two by 3 are the
same
2 by 3 is called the simplest form
it means this cannot be reduced further
but how did we know what number we are
supposed to divide them by
the number 6 is actually the highest
common factor of the numerator and the
denominator
if we divide the numerator as well as
the denominator by the hcf
we get the simplest form
say we have the ratio 30 by 50.
let's assume that we do not know what
their hcf is
if we do not know what the hcf is all we
need to do is look for the common
factors of the numerator and the
denominator
30 and 50 are both divisible by 2
so we divide the numerator as well as
the denominator by 2.
30 divided by 2 is 15
and 50 divided by 2 is 25
if there are no common factors of the
numerator and the denominator
it leaves us with the answer in the
standard form
but 15 and 25 both have 5 as their
common factor which tells us that this
is not the simplest form
we divide the numerator as well as the
denominator by five
fifteen divided by five is three
and twenty-five divided by five is five
the numbers three and five do not have
any common factors apart from one
so this is the standard form of the
ratio thirty by fifty
the product of all the numbers which we
divided the numerators and the
denominators by will be the hcf
here 2 times 5 which equals 10 is the
hcf of 30 and 50.
i would recommend you to first find the
hcf
and then divide the numerator and the
denominator by just once instead of
performing division several times
you